so last time we saw sandor clegane on
game of thrones that he had obtained of
George RR Martin's Song of Ice and Fire
he is left for dead by Arya Stark with
wounds sustained in his brutal and
really quite gratuitous fight with
Brienne of Tarth a fight which in the
books never happened the injuries that
put down the Hound were actually from
the fight of the crossroads in but in
any case we are led to believe that
Sandor Clegane is dead however we don't
actually see him die there's a theory
known as the gravedigger theory that the
Hound not only lives but appears in a
Brienne chapter of a feast for crows
after his supposed death in a storm of
swords
so what actually happens in that chapter
and why does it suggest that Sandor
Clegane is alive in this chapter Brienne
and companions are trying to find the
Hound in the belief that he has Sansa
Stark he actually has or had Arya
but either way Brienne swore an oath to
find the both of them for their mother
Catelyn the point is that Brienne and
Coe while searching for the Hound passed
through a small island in the Riverlands
called the quiet Isle which is inhabited
by brothers of the faith of the seven
who have made vows of silence so Brienne
talks with the elder brother of the only
man on the island allowed to speak even
by the way what kind of amounts to a
hobbit hole and the older brother tells
her to were surprised that the Hound is
already dead he says that he came across
the dying sand or nursed him until his
death and buried him he then talks for a
bit about the nature of the Hound about
the hounds horse who is now in the
brothers stable and about himself
Brienne tells the brother her life story
reaffirms her vow to find Arya and/or
Sansa and the chapter ends how is this
interpreted to suggest that the Hound is
still alive it's in the details so the
elder brother does say that the Hound is
dead but when telling his own story the
older brother also says that he himself
died in the Battle of the Trident this
is obviously not a literal death but a
metaphorical death the end of one
identity and the emergence of another
for which the older brother involved a
spiritual awakening which took him to
the faith and to the quiet Isle what he
calls his second life so the fact that
the elder brother talks about life and
death in this metaphorical sense calls
into question his saying that Sandor
Clegane is dead maybe it too is a
metaphorical death
well actually the elder brother only
ever says that the how
is dead that the man you hunt is dead
the most he'll say about sandor clegane
is that he is at rest so what the elder
brother could be getting at is that the
hateful violent part of Sandor Clegane
called the Hound is metaphorically dead
leaving Sandor Clegane at rest and most
importantly for us literally alive if
he's alive though where is he well on
the way of the quiet Isle Brienne sees a
brother digging graves who matches
Sandor pretty much perfectly firstly
he's described as being bigger than
Brienne Bryan is huge well over six feet
tall according to george RR martin the
hound is one of the few people in
Westeros who is or maybe bigger secondly
the man is described as being lame and
half crippled Sandor could well be lame
given his leg was seriously wounded at
the crossroads in as was the rest of it
really thirdly Brienne sees the grave
digger pausing his work to scratch a
dog's ear it makes sense that sander
would show affection for the animal that
is his sigil and it's a nice little
symbolic hint that the gravedigger has
some connection with hounds finally the
gravedigger is said to be a novice of
the brothers which he would be if he was
a recently joined brother of the quiet
Isle one other important detail is that
many of the brothers of the quiet Isle
where lengths of wool around their lower
halves of their faces along with robes
so that all that can be seen of them are
their eyes what this means is that the
distinctive features of the Hound ie the
disfiguring burns on his face wouldn't
be seen or recognized by Brienne her
companions or anyone else
so this gravedigger is suspiciously like
Sandor Clegane a final piece of evidence
involves the hounds horse named stranger
the horse is known to have an extremely
violent temperament biting and kicking
anyone who was in Sandor the brothers
are quiet Isle and no exception stranger
broke one brothers shin and bit an ear
off another so if we had to believe that
sound local gain really did literally
die how on earth or on whatever the
hell's kind of planet our song the bison
virus said on did the elder brother get
stranger to the quiet Isle what makes it
really implausible is the nature of the
path to quiet Isle
when Brienne and companions are taken to
the Isle we see what Septon Mirabal
calls the path of faith it's apparently
the only way to the isle that it's a
maze like unmarked natural paths at
least a mile and a half
long across an expanse of mud where you
have to be careful where you set your
feet or you'll be swallowed by quicksand
or end up drowning when the tide comes
in it's so dangerous that when septon
Mirabal bleeds Brianne and cola he has
to periodically stop and poke the ground
ahead with his staff to find safe
passage
can we really believe that the older
brother on his own took such a wild and
dangerous horse on such a treacherous
path why would the older brother even
risk trying what makes far more sense is
that while the hound metaphorically dies
sandor clegane is literally well and
metaphorically healed by the elder
brother who by the way is said to have
miraculous healing hands so the one man
who can control stranger walks the path
of faith with the elder brother in
relative safety and becomes a novice of
the brothers it seems likely that the
elder brother becomes a friend or mentor
to Sandor as this would explain the deep
knowledge the brother has of his nature
so there you go
there is pretty compelling textual
evidence or strong hints at least that
Sandor Clegane is still alive living as
a monk of sorts on quiet Isle and
possibly atoning for a life of violence
just as the elder brother is atoning for
his career as a soldier it gives a
really satisfying if entirely implicit
conclusion to his character arc the
Kisan door is a significant and complex
character unlike his brother who seems a
simple beast to the core Sandor has some
sensitivity some humanity which he hides
behind a quite literal mask of
thoughtless animalistic aggression the
hound it's not entirely unlike Tyrion
and dwarfism never forget what you are
wear it like armor but it's rather more
like Slim Shady and Marshall Mathers if
I can use that analogy with a straight
face aggression to hide emotional
insecurity you know anyway so Sandor has
two identities boned and unburned hound
and man brutal and kind fearless and
fearful fire and ice and this conflict
hurts him driving him to drinking and
disregard for his own life I aliefs the
hunter dead and in a way the Hound does
die the elder brother helps Santo
exorcise his dacha half removed the
hound helmet for good and find peace and
rest at the quiet Isle
this is why the older brother lies to
Brienne or
these chooses to be a tad indirect with
the truth it's understandable that the
older brother would want to protect his
new novice this man who he has worked to
enlighten and with whom he probably
identify its given their similar pasts
it's funny in a way is one of the only
characters in the Song of Ice and Fire
to get a happy ending while the
honorable men and the heroic men are
killed and is credited there's no
justice in the game of Thrones
wrongdoers not only get away with their
crimes but often end up better off than
the good guys
the grave digger Theory can be seen as
consistent with that theme one last
thing and this is where show Watchers
should stop watching this video spoiler
warning spoiler warning spoiler warning
it's kind of obligatory at this point to
recognize that many fans of A Song of
Ice and Fire not only believed that
sandal is alive on quiet Isle but expect
him to return to King's Landing to
confront he's now undead and possibly
headless brother Robert strong in
Circe's trial by combat this theory or
rather this wild fanboy speculation is
known as cleganebowl oh excuse me it's
known as
[Music]
the evidence fickle gain ball doesn't
extend far beyond it would be like
totally awesome man while it's true that
sound oh cool gain has wanted to kill
his brother for some time what we've
learned at the quiet Isle strongly
suggests he's gotten over that hatred
Sandor has put down his helm put down
his sword put down his anger and found
peace as a monk a tripled monk on a
secluded island far from King's Landing
how and why would he want to fight in
the trial why would anyone let him be
the champion of the faith monk or not
why would he not be executed the day he
walks into King's Landing given that the
last time he was there he abandoned the
king he was sworn to protect [ __ ]
there's just no compelling evidence so
cleganebowl has to be considered a
distant possibility at best albeit
totally awesome one
so yeah that's cleganebowl and that's
the gravedigger theory I hope you
enjoyed this video if you're interested
video explaining the deal with Robert
strong is a possibility among others so
let me know either way you can
definitely expect more A Song of Ice and
Fire fan Theory videos fairly soon if
you can't wait check out these sites for
what's probably the best of Song of Ice
and Fire discussion and analysis on the
Internet I'd like to make very clear
that I don't claim credit for coming up
with these theories I may add my own
ideas but they are ultimately a
collective effort notably by the users
of these sites so there are now Facebook
and Twitter pages for this channel if
you're into that sort of thing where you
can be notified of new videos or
whatever else is going on
finally I'd like to sincerely thank
everyone who has watched and subscribed
and shared and left comments over the
past week these videos exist because of
your support so thank you